it's great to welcome to the program
today Sam Harris who's a neuroscientist
philosopher New York Times bestselling
author post of the making sense podcast
and also creator of the waking up course
Sam I really appreciate your time and
I'm glad we we have the time to do this
today yeah likewise thanks for the
invitation so there's so many specific
things I would love to talk about and
I'm sure we'll get to some of them but
maybe just because this is the first
time we're talking and we've not before
and the sort of lines of political
discussion have really shifted in some
interesting ways in the last few years
what is your take on sort of like where
your place is now on the political
spectrum as it exists today and I asked
that with the context being that maybe
five years ago I would have believed you
to consider yourself very clearly on the
left of the political milieu in the
United States and I'm guessing you
probably still do but maybe with some
caveats that wouldn't have been there
five years ago I mean I don't know so
maybe let's start there yeah yeah you
know the truth is I don't really know
myself I don't have a clear sense of
what the the landscape is at the moment
I just know that if you go too far to
the left or to the right
you reliably meet lunatics
and so and that's it's become especially
a prep min it's always been clear to me
on the right and so as you say I always
considered myself on the left and I
still describe myself as a liberal but
III just I've it's now experienced so
much pain from what we think of as the
far left but the but the far left is so
mainstream now it's I mean it's you know
the geometry is all screwed up here
because if you talk about the far right
I still think you're talking about the
fringe you know a mature you know Trump
a stan is its own problem but you know
when people talk about the extreme right
you know when you're talking about the
people against whom
and Tifa would be demonstrating well
then you know you're talking about a you
know I don't know what the actual
numbers are but it seems like a fairly
small constituency when you're talking
about the extreme left where you're
you're meeting people who would deny
that there's you know any difference
between men and women that who would
accuse you know everyone inside of being
racist and would also assert that race
is the most important thing going
between human beings and can never be be
transcended or forgotten when I mean the
kinds of you know cultural war issues
I've stumbled into and gotten immense
blowback from the left that's a that's a
much more mainstream phenomenon I mean
that this you know what the actual
numbers are I don't know I'm have seen
some polling that suggests it's not
actually more than 8% of the population
but they've captured academia and
journalism and tech to an amazing degree
so and so it's it's all kind of warped
because you know obviously I find the
extreme right
generally scarier but the the mayhem and
just that the stifling of conversation
created by the the far left is is
something I've spent more time focusing
on of late so I go you know I get a lot
of pushback from the left which seems to
suggest that I'm a a person of the right
which I have never been I mean I'm a
registered Democrat I'm you know I've
never been tempted to vote for a
Republican and you know I've said as
much as anyone against Trump both before
and after the election so you know
that's that's where I am let's see if we
can look at some of those elements of
the left that you talk about because
what I've found in just generally being
aware of your work but then in sort of
more specifically preparing for this
conversation what I found is that a lot
of your critiques of what is
colloquially the colloquial
as the left I tend to agree with but
where I think maybe we disagree is the
importance and influence that maybe they
have so just to pick one of the things
that you mentioned people who believe
there's no difference between men and
women
where are they represented sort of in
the mainstream I guess is my question
because I as someone who pays attention
to both independent and corporate media
just so I can do my show so to speak and
talks to people in all sorts of
different political spaces at in-person
events that I go to at political rallies
at whether it's Harvard or MIT or
wherever here in the Boston area where
there's a talk I just never have met
anyone who holds that view now of course
that's merely anecdotal but the point is
in all of my sort of travels I've read
that that exists but it never seems to
have any kind of prominent role in the
sort of more prominent leftist
world so how how can we defend the idea
that it is mainstream in some way well
it's it comes down to what you can get
in trouble for saying I guess I mean
what you can get cancelled over what
people on Twitter would would try to
rouse the mob against you for and what
corporations and and journals and other
institutions would do in response so I
mean there's just a few you know
emblematic cases that that come to mind
around the gender issue I guess you know
the the Google memo is the thing that
that everybody noticed and you know that
still gets logged in the popular
imagination as a fairly egregious
eruption of misogyny on the part of
James d'amour and you know for which he
was rightly punished and yet it it
wasn't that right I mean this was this
was like a B+ paper in human biology
written by a fairly ASPI fellow who was
just sick of the kind of Maoist
indoctrination he felt he was
experiencing in Google
around gender issues and tech and and
mr. the what's happened on the left and
again this is a fairly mainstream
opinion although it's hard to point to
where it's expressed is the it's it's
now widely assumed that that unless you
have a 50-50 representation in every
field the the explanation for the the
disparity you find there has to be
sexism or misogyny right so unless 50%
of software developers are women you've
got a problem on your hands you've got a
recruiting problem you've got an
education problem some white male
[ __ ] is responsible for this and that
is a massively you know widely
distributed opinion even if it's not
always consciously entertain that way I
guess not sure that I don't know I I
want to really so I'm open to that being
the case and whenever I study these
things and you you would not know this
but I've often on been an adjunct
professor at Boston College where I
actually went in anticipating a lot of
the things that I've heard you talk
about and it
I've not observed it anywhere near to
the degree that you're describing so to
speak and I'm wondering if there is some
feedback mechanism by which these
egregious examples that you know about
and I know about are sort of signal
boosted to the point where both sides
are giving them more attention than they
deserve well I think that's true
ya know so I guess there's there's two
measures of of influence here is it one
is just the the sheer numbers of people
are the percentage of people who hold a
view and then there's just the the
consequences of whatever number of
people holding it whatever those
consequences are so yeah and I think
there is a signal boost I think I think
social media and the the outrage machine
we've we've created online I think that
is is largely to blame but academia and
tech
and journalism are captured by that to
an amazing degree right so even if it's
only 8% I mean this is one of the the
you know strange properties of networks
where you can a very vocal minority can
distort the the a hundred percent of the
conversation right and in large measure
I think this has given us you know Trump
and the the populist wave that he's been
riding that you there are so many people
who are fed up with you know what we've
often referred to as political
correctness and you know the this whole
constellation of taboos and and
injunctions and and yet it's so there's
there's a there's there is a kind of
silent majority I think that have been
sidelined yet and they're they're you
know they're not all right of center
many of them are left of center and I
meet many of these people so I have the
experience that I think you're referring
to which is when you meet people face to
face you don't find a ton of takers for
you know the deep platforming of
everyone and and you know threats of
violence in response to people like you
know ben shapiro or charles murray when
they come to a college campus
yeah but the effect of the minority that
does this is is pretty extreme and and
occasionally you do meet the people who
who appear to have been fully captured
like if you go to like the TED
conference yeah that conference is so
woke now it is oppressive I mean every
single talk that touches raised however
obliquely is just the I mean that
there's there is there is no realistic
discussion of anything it is just a very
expensive virtues virtue signaling
performance and you know I say this as a
fan of Ted who you know has spoken there
and and now and I go as an attendee most
years I mean I want Ted to succeed but I
mean with the conversation
the maybe it really is a kind of
caricature of the elite conversation
that it's being had and and being
maligned you know at you know outside
the the you know outside those
particular tents whether it's Ted or
Davos or anywhere else and you know you
then you have the the the reaction to it
which is Trump and you know people like
Mike sorowitsch and it's like a day but
they all have a point because it really
is that skewed inside some of those
tents and and so you know that that's I
I spend more time there than I spend in
the heartland of America you know
meeting people who actually voted for
Trump but I you can see what they're
tired of when you when you go in my
circles I completely am on board with
the idea that these sort of Fringe and
emblematic events and examples that you
talk about are extremely sort of
motivating but motivating is not the
right word maybe activating or
catalyzing for the people that you
listed for whether it's Trump voters or
Serna vich followers or whoever that
part I I agree with I guess where I from
a pragmatic perspective think about this
is you know I like to consider myself a
critic of the left in the areas where I
think that it's deserved and I want to
not only be focusing on the areas of the
left that I think are problematic but I
want want to be doing it in a proportion
that I think makes sense given the
influence I believe it has and on a lot
of these areas I am just not there in
terms of believing that the influence is
what some say that it is well again to
some degree my focus here is distorted
by my own experience because my
experience is is of being someone with a
fairly large platform who has been
repeatedly attacked for beliefs that I
don't hold right and don't even don't
even remotely hold
so and so I'm attacked as a you know I
mean as a last week I think it was I
decided that the best use of my podcast
was to get on there and speak for 45
minutes about you know why I'm not a
white supremacist right and this is just
after having looked at what's been said
about me on reddit for continuously ever
since I had Charles Mari on my podcast
you know over a year ago
maybe it was two years ago I've
forgotten so and this is what you know
and this is this is mainstream I mean
this was there was a Washington Post
article written about me and a few other
people again last week ascribing to us
in the we were basically the gateway to
the radical racist right you know the
altar right the the neo-nazis I mean
it's I'm part of the same conversation
for having had charles murray on my
podcast and spoken honestly about the
science right and it's you know i have
zero interest in the topic i of you know
race and IQ i have a lot of interest in
the topic of the suppression of free
speech and and just open inquiry and so
I had I had Maria my podcast after he
had been attacked at at Middlebury and
maybe actually physically attacked at
Middlebury 25 years after he wrote his
offensive book and then as I'm sure you
know Ezra Klein yeah wrote several
articles attacking me essentially as a
racist you know or is a racialist
pseudo-scientists knowing full well that
all his readers would read racialist as
as a synonym for racist and in and to
follow on directly from that I have the
Southern Poverty Law Center putting me
on their hate watch page you know as a
result of Ezra's articles right so you
know if 30 years from now my daughter's
read in my obituary that you know I was
repeatedly dogged by accusations of
racism it will be because of people I
guess recline and I'm you know given
that I've taken elaborate steps
to be very hard to cancel I can weather
this but most people can't right and
most people wouldn't want to and and I
hear from these people I hear from you
know absolutely top-shelf mainstream
best-selling scientists who utterly take
my side in that particular dispute right
but people who don't want to go on
record who'll privately after something
like that happens to you you hear from
you know everyone I mean just you know
the most famous scientists you can think
of who want to privately tell you that
they did they take your side in this but
they don't want to they don't want to
touch the topic with a ten-foot pole
because they there they perceive
themselves you know whether this is true
or not in many cases it is but they
perceive themselves to be vulnerable you
know even if they're tenured they just
don't want the mob to come for them
right and so this is this is an utterly
mainstream that this the silencing
effect is utterly mainstream whether
it's easy for people to notice what are
the topics you think it's it's not okay
to talk about under this paradigm of
what you see on the left as attempts to
suppress certain conversations well I
mean it's sort of everything you just
look at Dave Chappelle's the last
special did you did you watch that I've
only seen the first ten minutes so far
okay well then you're then you you
aren't yet into the the swampy he goes
racing through but I mean it's oh yeah I
thought it was very funny and very brave
but and something that could not have
been accomplished by most other comics
right I mean again he's sort of
uncounseled and yeah so it's he also has
the the freedom as a comic to take risks
that you and I can't take but there are
very few comics who could have gone so
hard at these issues you know maybe
Ricky Gervais is another one but you
know the others would have
you know that would've been their last
special for Netflix had they had they
received the blowback he's getting it's
yummy it's anything to do with race and
gender and I mean any inconvenient
finding from science that could just
come tumbling out of the lab could prove
to be a kind of political emergency and
we never know where these are going to
come from right miss the point I made
with decline for which he had no
response in the podcast we did and who
would think that this is even you know
on the map to be worried about but I
pointed out that in 2014 when we you
know finally got a genome sequence for
the Neanderthal DNA it was found that
basically everyone on earth except for
people who are directly descended from
Africa has something like you know 2.7
to 3 percent Neanderthal DNA right and
at the time I tweeted attention all
racists you were right White's are
special we're part in the end earth all
blacks are just human right and that's
me you know did taking a an unprovoked
dig at the racist of the world and and
just kind of goofing on this this this
headline about Neanderthal DNA but I
asked you know Ezra and I asked you know
everyone to imagine what would have
happened had the data fallen the other
way
what if only black people were pardoned
and earth all what then what happens to
the scientist who finds that what
happens to the journalist who reports it
we know what we absolutely know what
happens to them right their careers are
over in the current environment that's
completely insane it just doesn't matter
whose part in the end earth all right it
can't matter we have to get we have to
get ourselves to a political part of the
landscape where we are are
not vulnerable to what whoever happens
to fall out of a an interrogate and
honest interrogation of the nature of
reality right and it was just so and
this stuff is gonna keep coming fray
yeah especially out of behavioral
genetics I mean that's that's going to
be unless we're ready to absorb it that
is going to be a fount of toxicity right
when you think though along these lines
about the policy that as someone on the
left you would like to see adopted are
there ways specifically in which these
ideas or untouchability on you mentioned
race gender an inconvenient science is
this affecting sort of mainstream
leftist policy debate in a significant
way and I'm asking it not rhetorically I
mean I'm actually asking and in thinking
through the platform's of people who are
you know wanting to be the Democratic
nominees for example for president or
running at the state level for the
senator the House of Representatives are
to whatever degree you and I might agree
or disagree that these perspectives
exist on the Left are they entering into
the mainstream policy discussion yeah
well I would raise another category
which has been very influential and
that's religion specifically Islam so
you know I think the fact that Hillary
Clinton did not become president was
over determined there are many reasons
why that happened but one reason was
that she had absolutely nothing sensible
to say about the link between jihadism
and and jihadist violence and the
doctrine of Islam right so in the
immediate in the immediate aftermath of
Orlando you know at that point the
biggest the worst shooting in American
history all she could say was don't be
racist and Islam as a religion of peace
right and at that point it was
absolutely clear that that was just a
you know hallucination of woken us right
that yummy no one could even imagine she
believed but she was just paying lip
service to what you know the the Council
of American Islamic relations demands
and and you know what the left demands
what the left demands that you know that
we label any scrutiny any special
scrutiny of Islam as synonymous with
racism or motivated by racism can you be
more specific though Sam about because
because when you say the left I try I
try to avoid any generalizations of that
kind because I'm on the left and I don't
do those things and I I don't agree with
those perspectives and off and I I
suffer the repercussions can is there
any more narrow way in which we can
define where we find these elements of
the left I mean you've mentioned
academia but it's it's not all academia
at least not in my experience how might
we be able to narrow where this is
coming from
well it certainly most I mean the fact
that Islamophobia is a a word that is
now just used as intended as a term of
propaganda that conflates any criticism
of Islam as a set of doctrines with
bigotry against Muslims as people right
the fact the fact that Islamophobia
rolls off the the keyboards of
journalists at the New York Times as
easily as anti-semitism that is a you
know that's a new status quo which
contains the problem right if you
criticize Islam or you're more worried
about Islam than Mormonism you're an
Islamophobe right and this is just this
is very this is more common than not in
a university setting
I would imagine although I'm not in one
but you know everything you know all the
feedback I get suggests that this is a
majority opinion on the Left I mean I
think maybe you know you and I probably
both are only or for sure
only get incomplete pictures in that
there's some self-selection bias in
terms of who am i hearing from who are
you hearing from which campuses am i on
versus campuses I'm not
but I have to say that when I delve into
this stuff I do get the blowback exactly
that you describe but it's really quite
modest in size and I even assume it's
over-represented because people who
disagree with me are more likely to get
in touch than people who simply agree
and think nothing of it it III wish that
there were some way that rather than you
know speculating we could really be more
empirical about it in the way that we
can about some other things because I
feel as though we don't necessarily have
the most accurate sense of to what
proportion these these things are really
the big issues for the left well it's
just again there's a difference between
sheer numbers and influence so I can
tell you what I see you know on the the
opinion page and you know on the
journalistic side of you know papers
like the New York Times or The
Washington Post and when you look at how
you know I get treated or someone
further to the right of me like you know
Jordan Peterson would get treated in
those contexts or you know if you're
further to the right still been Shapiro
and when you look at how how Trump gets
treated I mean again I think Trump is as
OD as a character as I can think of
really I mean some ways more odious than
people who are objectively worse right I
mean some ways that you know I have more
respect for someone like Osama bin Laden
than I do for Trump for a variety of
reasons but so it might my animus toward
Trump is it can you know verges on the
paradoxical is it because of the lack of
you know you don't find Trump genuine in
a way that you find or found Osama bin
Laden genuine or I'm interested in that
yeah there's something there I mean it's
it's I think in my model of Osama bin
Laden's mind is that he actually could
have been a a psychologically healthy
deeply ethical person and truly
compassionate person ruled by some
terrible ideas
and this is what worries me most about
jihadism I mean I see jihadism as the
kind of perfect mind virus where you can
actually be a good person
but if you're captivated by these ID
ideas you can behave in a way that you
know not even the worst Psychopaths get
up to most of the time right and so
there's you know that that's one form of
violence and that's one you know
typology of it and but it but but in
Trump I see a genuinely disordered
personality right he seems like he has
no moral core right I mean if I believed
in souls and you told me that you know
his his had been removed you know that
would account for for the problem I mean
I just see I see somebody who is so
naked ly selfish and narcissistic and
unmoored to any value system that I
recognize that he actually he's there's
something scarcely human about him
I mean he's he's so in that sense he's
actually worse than people who have who
have created much more harm
intentionally someone like Osama bin
Laden I mean I recognize in you know
sama bin Laden I recognize a fully human
person running some very bad software
your Trump Trump does not seem that way
to me
he has no ideology that I can detect
apart from his own self concern and you
know he's just like he's he's he strikes
me as a kind of moral lunatic right and
I wouldn't say that of most jihadists
you know frankly now given the severity
of that indictment morally of Trump what
is your perspective on someone who votes
for Trump I mean is that there there has
to be I'm guessing some accounting for
if you are so easily able to discern
this reality about Donald Trump how do
you understand and interpret someone who
says despite all of those things I just
heard Sam say I'm gonna go and vote for
the guy well I got I think a lot of
people don't see this about him I mean
that's that's one I mean a lot of people
don't
dishonesty to the degree that I do I
find his lying and its consequences for
our politics you know one of this is
probably the most objectionable thing
about him but so people people don't
really care about that they just they
they have a few memes rattling around
their heads like you know all
politicians lie as though that you know
there was some kind of equivalence
between you know catching catching Obama
or Clinton or anyone else in a lie and
what Trump gets up to every day so and I
think there's just the in part it comes
back to where we started this
conversation people are so sick of the
status quo and the falsity of what they
perceive the the quote elites to be
advertising to them that and Hillary
Clinton was you know almost the the
perfect case of somebody who seemed to
lack you know kind of a genuine set of
ideas I mean ironically Trump in being
the the biggest liar anyone who's ever
seen manages to rebrand his dishonesty
as a kind of authenticity right I mean
he's he's just being himself yes right
he's and he's and he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the consequences and that is
so refreshing
that's so refreshing for people they and
so he just steamrolled through
Republican politics with that kind of
superpower where he just was not going
to honor any ones norms and there are so
many I mean there you know there's
different segments of the population who
support him there are people who just
want to see it all burn right so there's
kind of a nihilism that just wanted to
roll the dice with with change so
radical and and you know non-ordinary a
nun governor bowl that they just you
know it was just
they just want to throw a a Molotov
cocktail into the center of our politics
to see what would happen but it's not
all that it's people who just cannot
believe how many people are being
accused of being racist or sexist or
Islamophobic and you know where does
this stop right I say some I mean I'm
sort of thinking through these examples
and so one was you mentioned that the
sort of dissatisfaction or being sick
and tired of elites as one reason why
people went to Trump isn't Trump the
epitome of the elite I mean he's the New
York born to a rich dad who gave him a
small loan of a million dollars he is by
a small loan of 400 million dollars or
it was or even you know when you talk
about like if people are sick and tired
of people being accused of being racists
I don't know how that gets you to say I
would vote for Hillary other than I
don't like people being accused of
racism so I'm voting for Trump like oh
it seems like only the most lacking in
all information voter might consider
such a such a decision well there are
many people who just lack information
right so you know there are many people
who voted for Trump who assumed that he
really was this brilliant businessman
and that his you know how he seemed to
be on the apprentice you know the year
after a year you know this this true
captain of industry was in fact his real
bio right and he wasn't just a a
Sherlock Meister you know Brander of
property he didn't build in many cases
and you know just an actual thief right
I mean he just is a guy who's trailing
thousands of lawsuits you know me just
as their single examples from his
biography that should have been totally
disqualifying for him interesting you
know Trump University yes how that was
run the fact that he would pretend to
you know he would claim to give money to
to charities
without really giving
money to the charities and he would show
up at the ribbon-cutting who'd crash a
ribbon-cutting for for PR purposes you
know at a hospital or some other charity
even veterans charities which is sort of
a sacred cow in fact for some of the
electorate he was trying to appeal to
exactly and and and never give a dime
all right so it's just it's some so
people don't have that information and
they're not disposed to seek it out and
they're so but it's just something truly
perverse happened I mean the people just
loved to see the reaction he was getting
from the left and from the the center
and from the even from the never Trump
errs on the you know on the right or the
center-right they just loved the
spectacle and he turned the entire world
into a reality TV show and we're still
in it and and people there was just
something it's it was a kind of perfect
storm of of American failings coming
together I mean our our our kind of bill
which meant by media and fame and the
fact that you know if you can just get a
laugh at a debate you know you win right
if you just get a laugh at somebody
else's expense this is the nature of our
political debates where you just if you
have a line that doesn't sound
pre-written
by your staff and you can manage to
deliver it naturally and you can get
people back footed by it and to get a
laugh from the audience you have won the
debate unrelated to anything else that
was said about policy or wasn't said you
know and so when you know Trump it says
you know only Rosie O'Donnell
you know off-the-cuff you know he wins
right and it's that's how we elect a
president in this country it's madness
but that's that's where we are and until
we can figure out how to break this
spell you know where we'll be vulnerable
to more of this you know I mean one of
the scariest things about Trump is is to
contemplate what an actual evil gene
his could do with his skills right I
mean it's like he I mean III view him as
a kind of I've compared him to you know
that the character Chauncey Gardiner in
in the film and book being there you
know where he was just he just happened
to be a kind of imbecile who's whose
limitations showed up as strengths given
the context right now so I just view him
as a kind of evil Chauncey Gardiner but
he's not really an evil genius right
he's not really someone who can hide his
true personality in a calculated way he
just blurts out what whatever's on his
mind and in the current environment it
happens to work or at least it works
with 40% of Americans and that's enough
it's enough to lack serious
repercussions in any case yeah you've
mentioned so in the course of our
conversation so far you've you've talked
about the problems with to borrow a term
I first heard at least made made more
prominent by Eric Weinstein sense-making
you've criticized academia for the way
in which sense making goes off off the
rails when left to them you've been
critical of corporate media you've
talked about how many of our elected
officials certainly can't be trusted to
to sort of make sense of the world
around us you talked about a lot of
Trump voters and I'm sure you've
believed the same about voters who
didn't vote for Trump there's a lot of
people who just lack information to make
informed decisions
so who I mean what what is the direction
that you believe we should be going in
in terms of who should be doing the
sense-making is is there anyone that can
be trusted well unfortunately there's no
one who can I mean it doesn't there's no
one who can always be trusted there
there's a process that can be trusted
and you know science for all its
failings has the the best version of it
but I mean it just just kind of
open-ended rational conversation
generally is the algorithm
you know intellectual honesty is the
algorithm so I mean the example
used in my last podcast when I was
taking the you know the allegations of
white supremacy off of me I mean to some
degree they had come because I hadn't
jumped on the bandwagon in calling Trump
a racist for specific things like
telling Ilan Omar and the rest of the
squad to go back to where they came from
right it that didn't seem like a clean
example of racism to me and I you know
I've always said that I think Trump is a
racist and I see examples of racism you
know in his you know bio but even
someone who you know is a racist you you
can't hold them accountable for for
everything that can possibly be spun as
evidence of racism when it's when it's
bad evidence of racism because if that
evidence is going to stand for Trump it
has to it will then stand for other
people right so no we're all going to be
hosted by that same news because it's
it's just it has to be Universal
izybelle so if if telling someone to go
back to where they came from is a sure
sign of racism well you have to be able
to map it on to other contexts and here
was the context where I thought okay
Trump is such an imbecile
he might not know that the other three
members of the squad aren't also
immigrants right he'll on Omar came from
Somalia right so that she fit the type
he was targeting maybe he was just
talking about her maybe he thought that
you know all of these women have funny
names they're probably all immigrants
maybe he didn't have you I I don't I
don't give him the credit to have
thought about it for more than two for
even two seconds before his thumbs
started moving on his smartphone right
in a so that could be argued to be kind
of like an aggravating I mean I don't
need to go over that particular case too
much you could make the case that it
actually it was their brown-skinned
rather than their actual country of
origin that wound him up and got him to
say this and that in that it's actually
an aggravating factor for making the
case of actual racism one can say that
you know no it could be it's just that I
could imagine a circumcision I were and
Ireland with some failing state and you
said you know go back to you know go
back to your your own country and and
you know solve that potato famine and
then tell us you know how to run our
lives
that wouldn't be racist you know from a
a you know a current white supremacist
point of view it would be you know it
would be an objectionable thing to say
perhaps but it's just not a you know it
just doesn't fit you know the racist
template and so it just wasn't good
evidence no but I mean because a white
guy saying Irish people should go back
to Ireland by definition it does it
would not be racist I don't know that it
proves or disproves the particulars of
that one doesn't you know but my point
is you don't you don't need to be sloppy
in making allegations against Trump I
mean he's such a he there's so much
attack surface there right this this too
much right I mean this is another point
about him is that if he were one-tenth
as bad he would seem worse I'm he's just
so bad that we just we can't even keep
in mind the thing he did at 10:10 a.m.
this morning because by 2:00 p.m. he's
done five other things right so so I
mean I think the left and you know the
end and by left here I mean a mainstream
journalism really suffers from being
sloppy here and do you consider
mainstream journalism left because my
view is more of a corporatist analysis
which is that yeah you you know you've
got MSNBC which editorially editorially
is left or center left Democratic and
Fox News has its view and then you've
got you know the blaze and Breitbart and
whatever but I time it and again and end
up coming to the conclusion that really
there is a profit motive and sort of
establishment as the sense makers
priority more than being left right or
Center app absent you know some examples
of small or media outlets I'm guessing
maybe you see it differently well I I
think
mostly if places like the New York Times
right just what would be said about
Trump in the New York Times and how how
accurate will it be right and and the
pro the problem is that this is just a
symmetrical warfare every error in the
New York Times matters errors on Fox
News don't matter as errors cut to their
to their bases and and today or enter
even to the to the really to anyone it's
like we we you and I expect Fox News to
get it wrong a lot yes and it's and
that's just that's built into our
understanding of what that platform is
it's not real journalism I mean
occasionally it will produce factual
reporting no doubt but it is a it's a
platform of advocacy pretending to be
journalism much of the time and you know
Trump's errors and lies as we've
observed don't matter to his base and in
many cases they're not even I mean
they're they're they're truly features
they're not even bugs that they're you
know overlooking they're just this is
part of the fun just winding up the Lib
tardes with lives but when that when the
New York Times gets it wrong it matters
to you know a supporter and subscribe
and subscribe or like myself and it also
matters it's also used against us by the
right and by by Trump supporters to me
it really is a very long armed lever
that gets pulled because you know just
one error gets seems to justify
allegations of fake news and you know
trumped arrangement syndrome and let me
see you got this wrong basically
everything's wrong right
and then then we're just on some you
know greased ramp debt sliding down to
pizza gate and you know there's just
there's no such thing as facts anymore
and it's a very disorienting asymmetry
but it's a powerful one because I mean
you can see it I mean I see it all the
time
on issues where I
you know and unusually well-informed you
know whether it's you know jihadism and
and Islam or and even the gun debate
right me you routinely see reporting and
editorials written by people who clearly
don't know anything about firearms right
they get everything wrong and then you
then you have the the gun owning world
which is actually filled with people who
don't totally aligned with the NRA and
the people who are open to or even
encouraging of changes to our laws and
who want you know more intrusive
background checks and all of that but
you you that they read these these
editorials or articles or they see you
know somebody on CNN talking about the
latest latest shooting and you know that
the implications for for gun policy and
they just see just this this torrent of
ignorance coming their way
and and ignorance and kind of panic that
is out of proportion often to the facts
I mean you would never know it but you
know apparently gun school shootings
have have gone down you know
precipitously since the 90s right but
you know we're not speaking I mean no
one is disposed to speak as though that
were the case in the current environment
and you know crime crime has gone down
you know almost across the board you
know maybe there's been slight uptick
sand in various cities but you know
generally speaking you know that at the
time that you were likely to have gotten
murdered in the US was in you know 1994
not not today also winters unless I'm
curious if you've seen otherwise but
I've not seen anything linking that to
the availability or ownership of
firearms right I mean you're these are
broad trends that you've reserved them
yes yeah and and and the you know the
gun control question is a genuinely
difficult puzzle to solve but it clearly
has to be solved in the the context of a
conversation that will just honestly
talk about the
facts and so I like here's one taboo
fact that you can get cancelled on the
left or you know you you know anywhere
in the mainstream for touching but and
this is the kind of thing that Trump
touches in his you know with with with
all his bigoted topspin but the fact
that the left can't acknowledge that
there's a kernel of truth in his
utterances here is a problem and that is
just a disproportionate amount of
violence in the black community upon the
black community right so black on black
violence is still terrible in the US and
accounts for are largely accounts for
our outlier status with respect to
homicides is that unique though in the
sense that I was recently reviewing some
of the data on that and I'm going from
memory so I might get the numbers just
slightly off but what I recall is
something like if there is a black
person who has been the victim of
violence there's a low 90s percent
chance that the perpetrator was also
black and that a white person who was
the victim of violence was a very
similar number it was an you know call
it 89 or 91 percent chance that the
perpetrator there was white and it
seemed to be extremely similar and
that's where I think that some you know
I was on a I remember where it was where
someone someone on the right said the
epidemic of black on black violence and
I said confronted her with this data and
we really didn't get anywhere but that
the numbers don't seem to necessarily
bear out what you're saying
oh no they no they they do bear out the
numbers you just gave bear out what I'm
saying so I mean and these are the
numbers as I understand them again it's
been a while since I've actually looked
at data but this is you know close
enough you know your as you say if you
are if you are white you are more likely
to have been murdered by a white person
and if you're black you're you're much
more likely to be murdered by a black
person so it is kind of within each
community it's not I think the numbers
are almost it was like 90 and 92 percent
it seems like as a trend as inter race
violence is I think it's not as it's not
quite as happy
it's worse in one direction than the
other I mean it's it's overwhelmingly
like it likely that that it was black on
black crime the percentages of white
people killed by by black people are
higher than the other way and but the
thing gets may is especially invidious
when you just look at the percentages of
the population because when you're
talking about black on black crime or
black on white crime you were talking
about you know mostly black men right
it's not black women committing most of
these murders
so you're talking about 6 percent of the
population or there abouts right six
percent of the population commits
something like 50 percent of the murders
right now that sentence uttering this
sentence could get me cancelled but for
the the preparations I've made within my
own life to not be cancelable right this
is just a fact however but it's a fact
that only African Americans can speak
about without being destroyed and that
so this is absolutely a ton of it so
what what white Democratic candidate for
the presidency will speak honestly about
this fact it is the kind of thing that
gets you immediately compared to Richard
Spencer or some lunatic neo-nazi right
this is a this is just a social problem
for whatever its causes that we have to
get a handle on we as a society and and
and the black community especially and
again this is a problem which the black
community in in most respects suffers
from exclusively again almost all of
these murders are of black members of
the community bye-bye black young men so
you're talking about cities like Chicago
right which you know have neighborhoods
which are essentially war zones and this
was again this was much worse everywhere
in the 90s but to the degree that the
homicide rate is still intolerable in
the u.s. it is largely explained by
black on black
violence in the inner cities and again
it's like you just can't be a white guy
talking about this right and you know
Here I am on your podcast doing it but
it's this is the kind of thing that you
should be free to discuss and it's
absolutely necessary to discuss this
well it seems we have a full discussion
of it the immediate because people
people will hear that and they'll say
well it sounds like you are saying
something like black people are
inherently violent as an example right
well no I'm not saying I'm not saying
you're saying that to be clear but but
the but the flipside is people on the
left will demand that they know they
know what the explanation has to be for
this it has to be on some level white
racism or the legacy of white racism or
racist policies or racist policing or
racist economics or the war on drugs and
the the the incarceration machinery that
we've built all of that has given us
this problem and and the the remedy has
to be somehow combating racism as the
you know the first order of business
so let's now I mean what do you think it
is well I'm not saying all of them in
the the legacy effects of the war on
drugs have are still disastrous and and
you know I mean that is that is a war
that should never have been waged and
that is an education problem and a
medical problem it's not an it's not a
incarceration problem so we have to get
out of that business and that and that
those penalties have fallen as we know
disproportionately on on the black
community and on the you know the
non-white community generally but I mean
there there is a there's a conversation
to be had about the limits of racism as
an explanation for this problem right
what we have a cut at minimum we have a
cultural problem that has to be solved
and and you know only the black
community can really solve it I mean
this is some
and and on some level understanding the
origins even if we knew that the origin
of the problem was white racism you know
we have slavery we have Jim Crow and
then we have a direct you know just line
of falling dominoes to the problem of
inner-city violence you know for you
know black teenagers let's just say that
was true that still doesn't tell you
what the remedy is now I mean how do you
get people to live different lives now
and to value value their lives
differently well I think the cultural
element goes beyond just inner-city
communities I've talked about this
before which is you were very often will
hear from the you know always more guns
in more places folks they'll talk about
Switzerland for example and the high gun
ownership rate or there will be all
sorts of different comparisons made to
other countries and what I never see as
part of the problem when availability of
guns has talked about background checks
waiting periods or any of that is that
there is a cultural element in the
United States where guns are seen too
frequently as a tool with which you can
solve either a political problem or a
personal problem or a social problem or
a romantic problem with whatever group
of people that is that you would like to
be dating or whatever the case may be
that seems to be significantly different
than in many of these other countries
that are often point to do and that I
think is a much broader problem that's
not often discussed oh sure but that
affects all communities equally I mean
that's a white maybe a problem and maybe
there are communities I don't know I'm
just saying it could affect all
communities equally or maybe not well
when I think of of the religion of gun
ownership in this country and you know
the you know NRA support and and the the
greatest hostility to even the most
common-sense measures to you know
protect ourselves from from you know
guns falling into the wrong hands you
know again this could be a bit of a
caricature but I generally think of a
white guys and and not anybody
right now I would imagine if I were if
our Betty and I would think that that
that is a that a that is a white person
problem more than it is and from any
other community now we just have this we
have this general issue of the fact that
you know we can't uninvent these guns
and we've got more than 300 million of
them on the ground in the US and so
that's just how we get to a place where
it becomes difficult for the wrong
people to get their hands on a gun you
know who knows how we accomplished that
but no there's just this a this is a so
this is the third a a third rail of
political discourse for a reason right
because it's not easily amenable to a
socio-economic analysis or any other
analysis I mean you can get you go into
you know Latino areas in the same cities
with the same socio-economic
characteristics and you don't have the
same level of violence right so it's not
it's just a you know it's just something
that's not being talked about and to
talk about it if you have the if your
skin is the wrong color brands you as a
bigot and yet my only my concern in
talking about it is twofold my concern
is it would be really nice to have fewer
murders in this country right I mean I
you know every time you hear about
people getting shot you know both those
who died and those who live with
injuries I mean that is just an awful
you know intolerable status quo to be
you know not changing and then there's
just the the larger issue of what this
what the taboos around this conversation
does to our political discourse I mean I
I've you this has yet another reason why
we have someone like Trump because the
people who support Trump know they're
being lied to right I mean we had the in
the run-up to the election we had this
this kind of hysteria around you know
police violence and you know you
the shootings of young black men now
some of those cases were awful right
where you know it was clearly a you know
utter you know sadistic malpractice on
the part of cops who belong in prison
right but some were you know clearly
legitimate shootings and there was no
will on the you know once you went left
of center to speak honestly about the
differences there right and as far as I
can tell there's still no political will
this I've talked about this issue and
the me to movement with the me to
movement you know the idea that not
everything is the same the idea of you
know a forcible rape versus someone
masturbating in front of someone else
who was uncomfortable that there there
is a gap there and not not everybody is
Bill Cosby these are all different
things and for the most part it's been
relatively well received with with
regard to the shootings of young black
men I've also been able to sort of draw
some lines between different types of
incidents I think that this is once
again one of those issues where the the
loudest people and the ones you're most
likely to hear from are the ones who are
not interested in the more nuanced
discussion and that's certainly a
problem but the nuanced discussions I
think are definitely there we but
they're not there they're not coming
from presidential candidates right
they're not coming from I don't see them
honestly in the New York Times right I
mean they might be happening on podcasts
you know III do it and and perhaps you
do it but it's you know this is not this
has to be the kind of thing that you
know Pete Buddha Chege could say at a
debate and and not Reba world whirlwind
of hate for right I mean let's take
another example here again this just you
know there's so much will hanging fruit
here but so just I just mentioned Buddha
Church so Buddha Church is often asked
Hawaii has zero percent black support
right yeah and he responds like this is
one of the great you know mysteries of
the universe that it would take a team
of scholars and rabbis and Nobel
laureates to penetrate right he has
never once maybe he's changed but you
know to my ear he is never once uttered
and on a sentence on this topic you know
and he he'll he pivots to blandishments
like well you know they just haven't
heard the message yet or you know I just
got to get out there but the reality is
is that the level of homophobia in the
black community is off the charts right
because of and this is a you know you
largely this is it has to do with the
black church and the level of
religiosity in that community but you
know that's why he doesn't have black
support and you know is it important to
talk about that I don't know I mean it's
just but that what what is toxic here is
there are all these truths hiding in
plain sight that are going
unacknowledged right and you can do a
little bit of this I mean I'm not saying
that that we have to you know naked ly
broadcast the truth you know maternity
no matter the consequences but there's
there's just there's so much obfuscation
and lack of straightforwardness on the
left that it's the the the counter
reaction you know to it has been growing
for quite some time and it's um it's
it's massively energizing the right and
that's what as someone who's you know
first political goal is to see to it
that Trump doesn't get a second term
that's what I worry about it's like if
you can't speak honestly about facts
that everyone can observe or that it
takes five minutes to surface you know
it's just what is the path here to not
alienating a majority of people because
it's not just a matter of not speaking
honestly it's it's castigating fully
half of the society on many of these
points as racists or sexist or
misogynists or you know xenophobes and I
mean again to take take another topic
immigration
of course it's possible to be concerned
about immigration from a racist white
supremacist xenophobic perspective that
does not mean that that that genuine
concern about immigration is always
motivated by those sins right I mean
like it is as far as I can tell it is
only sane to want a defensible border
right and to want to know who's coming
into the country and to want to be able
to admit the people into the country who
you want into the country you know and
like why not have a policy that allows
for that well on the left you begin to
sound like a racist [ __ ] arguing for
a policy like that that's because you're
called one that's been III again I think
that that's a relatively small but
everybody who calls my show and talks
about this immigration issue is starting
from exactly that point that you're
starting from which is countries exist
if we recognize that countries exist
there's got to be a process there has to
be a border and I feel like there
there's probably more reasonable
conversation happening about that then
maybe is highlighted in corporate media
but but but it was but again it's not
even highlighted at the level of the you
know the Democratic debates I mean but
virtually every candidate had a either
explicit or implicit open borders policy
no see I don't see that at all that's
interesting that I did not I actually
didn't couldn't identify a single
candidate that had an effective open
borders policy well well it was a
centimeter they got to the punch line
when when I asked you know what what do
you do with respect to medical care for
people who get in and and it was again
this is this is to some degree just a
response to the emergency of Trump right
and we have we've got you know kids
being put in cages at the border and now
now our debate about immigration is
being held in that context yeah but it
seemed to be that you know we were going
to give lifetime free medical care to
anyone who could just get into the
country okay now that's funny that you
mentioned that because the day after I
said this is a losing issue for
Democrats the idea of you know the hand
raising about what we want I actually
just
don't know that that was even the way
the issue should have been framed but
you're completely right and I literally
said that I think within hours of the
debate I said this is this is a way to
lose the Trump which is starting to talk
about about this as the priority when
there are so many other things that
actually should be the priorities yeah
yeah or or take reparations right now
reparations for slavery is not something
I've thought much about I think my bias
is I mean my bias is certainly that it's
worth thinking about and may in fact be
the right thing yeah and I'm not quite
sure what the form is I mean how you do
it but and may and I'm I would not be at
all surprised that if I thought more
about it or and if I had more you have
had a conversation with people who were
had better ideas about it than I've
currently heard that I could be
convinced that not only would it be
acceptable but just it would be a moral
necessity to do it right so I I'm
totally open minded on the reparations
issue but you talk about another way to
lose to Trump right I mean this is let's
let's wait two years before we have this
conversation this is loose oh okay now
we finally got to one where what you
described is exactly as I've experienced
that that is almost word-for-word what
I've said and I got quite a bit of angry
pushback saying you know all of the
things that you would imagine could be
said it's a sum right who says yeah yeah
so I mean there's so many threads here
that that intersect in this in the same
space and it comes down to I mean on one
level I'm on that particular point it's
you know a lack of political pride
pragmatism but which you know we I don't
think we should ever lose sight of is
certainly not a year before an election
where more Trump is on the menu but it
it just it again it goes to like oh
we're just not in a position to have
open-ended conversations with a with a
basic principle of charity keeping
everyone at the table where you just
you're you're going to
assume that the other person has a point
of view that's worth taking seriously
based on the reasons they can adduce for
they're having it right and not based on
the color of their skin or you know
they're in some accident of birth but
just based on on a universe Eliza Belov
rationality which is we just have to
keep talking and examining the world and
keep course correcting and this is an
iterative process where the best idea
ultimately wins and to actually play
this game it doesn't matter who you are
right and it doesn't matter who it
doesn't matter on some level it's not
it's definitely not an appeal to
Authority either I mean obviously you
you know if you want opinions about
history you tend to go to historians if
you want to pinyons about neurology you
tend to go to neurologists but but on
some more fundamental level it's about
the ideas themselves and their fitness
and their and their degree of fit to the
facts as we know them and and when
you're really playing that game you're
only as good as your last sentence right
and it doesn't matter if you have a
Nobel Prize in the relevant area you you
know if you say something that doesn't
make sense you get immediate pushback
even from an undergraduate and that's
that's the way the game is played but at
no point in that process does it matter
you know that you're that you're gay or
trans or tall or short or black or white
I mean it's like we have to get to a
place where referencing any of those
variables yeah is just as absurd as
referencing tall or short or you know
the color of a person's hair right why
don't we have more blondes working at
Google right why don't we what we really
need is a blonde candidate for this
office well I think that it's not an
apples to apples comparison because
blonde is not a historically oppressed
group or I mean I think that just to
pick any characteristic and equated is
not totally precise well nobody
but I'm imagining what success looks
like yes or if there's a history of
oppression that again just coming back
to reparations on yeah I'm open-minded
on that topic but what would what would
a hard reset actually look like what
would a sane civil society look like
then it would really be just hair color
as far as the eye can see right it would
not be listen as a as a a person of
color who has suffered this the this
litany of injustice 'as I can say X Y &
Z but you can't say any of those things
as a white guy I mean if we're talking
about reality if we're talking about
things that scale if we're talking about
how whole societies should function
you know identity politics can't be the
algorithm it just can't I mean it's just
it's just a narrow form of tribalism
that can't possibly get at anything
Universal and you know and it and again
it it energizes its antithesis I mean in
this case it energizes white identity
politics which is the the most absurd
form of tribalism on offer and and it's
but it's in in full bloom right now in
our society apparently yeah that's
that's one area where we absolutely
agree salmon the sort of limited time we
have left I know we're getting to the
end here I did want to face with you
about white supremacy a little bit and
and manifestos because I was I took some
criticism years ago when I said a an
Islamic terrorist or perpetrator who
states that their motivations were
related to Islam should be considered
genuine and serious and while there may
be other aggravating factors which we
can talk about that that needs to be
taken seriously and I believe that and
in the same way when I hear about you
know a perpetrator that is apparently a
white supremacist who was participating
in all of the known places on the
Internet which I don't even need to name
and
naming them and they say that these were
motivating factors I believe unless I
have a really specific reason to think
otherwise I also believe that they're
genuine and I've seen that you've talked
about the idea of those right-wing
shooters sometimes in your opinion
writing a semi bogus manifesto maybe to
confuse the media maybe to get attention
and I I definitely don't see it that way
absent some evidence that would change
my mind so I'm curious how you came to
that conclusion you know it was just
based on hearing some evidence or
alleged evidence in that area and I'm
actually my next podcast is gonna be
with Kathleen below there's a a you know
historian on this topic of white
supremacy so I'll sort of dive deeper
into that and get a little more of an
education there but yeah I mean the the
issue seems to be that there's this this
other variant of you know troll culture
that is attracting in many cases
mentally unstable isolated you know
socially isolated young men some
percentage of whom are just be kind of
viewing opportunities for violence as a
kind of video game and this gets mixed
in with you know some level of racism or
white supremacy or misogyny or all of
those things and it's not clear you know
what really is the motivating factor I
mean said and again some in some cases
violence is over determined right so you
have someone who is is mentally ill but
is also enamored of some some bad you
know violence producing ideas and may
also have a legitimate grievance in the
world right and then that person goes
into a synagogue or a mosque or or a
school and kills people and then we're
left trying to sort out what was really
the the operating variables but
they're they're pure cases right of all
of these things to where it's just you
have psychologically normal people who
are motivated clearly by ideas and they
state those ideas and there's no reason
to doubt them right and so so there are
clear cases of every type I think it's
it's far more common to have socially
socially marginalized psychologically
unwell people go in and shoot up schools
and I think it's also far more common to
have people fitting that type join white
supremacist organizations than it is to
have those variables be the explanation
for jihadism may I did you the reason
why I think jihadism is different then
and I did a solo podcast on this topic
differentiate differentiating jihadism
from white supremacy I think it is it's
an importantly different set of ideas
and most important in a different
context right it's a jihadism is a is an
extremist set of ideas set within a
mainstream religion and disentangling
those ideas from the the mainstream
religious ideas that people truly care
about that that you know more than a
billion people truly care about is
genuinely difficult right and entails
theological hair-splitting that is
frankly not very convincing right so
it's it's a hard problem and it's for
this net for that reason attracting for
more you know straightforwardly
religious normal people into its ranks
white supremacy is not quite the same
right it's not it doesn't have it has
links to Christianity but the links are
not as direct and they're not as not as
broad and they're not as connected to
other things that are good about
Christianity right the things that
people normal people really want about
Christianity and so I think it is
filtering for you know unbalanced
more deranged people more marginal
people people who have less opportunity
and more grievances or pseudo grievances
but then there are cases where you know
the violence is coming from you know
just psychopathy or or other
psychopathology right we're we're then
then whatever lip service may or may not
be paid to ideas it really is just lip
service it's not really the ideas and
you don't know until you you know but a
null point as an example like I think
that the Columbine shooting is often
talked about in the context of these you
know online discussions of white
supremacist violence and I think Eric
Harris in his journals wrote a fair
amount about you know white supremacy
but you know one who's really looked at
the details of the Columbine shooting
thinks that this is a a clear case of
white supremacist violence I mean these
were really disturbed young men who
decided to kill their classmates and you
know it's that this was not the Oklahoma
City bombing which is which was clearly
ideological and so it's just you just
don't know until you know and when I
spoke about the El Paso shooting and
even the Christ Christ Church shooting
it just wasn't totally clear to me what
was what in terms of those manifestos I
mean it's a general idea I think that
there's something to that I guess where
I would disagree with you would be on on
two fronts one would be on the side of
the radical Islamic terror it is not
there there is definitely a selection
process that is taking place so I think
that maybe you overstate the sort of
emotional and psychological normality of
the individuals that do end up actually
perpetrating the acts that would be sort
of on on that side I think on the white
supremacy side I've interviewed a lot of
former neo-nazis and white supremacists
and invariably they all had chaotic
family lives and all of the exact sort
of circumstances that pulled them made
them susceptible to be pulled into a
community whose beliefs they then adopt
but I don't think that that makes the
white supremacy irrelevant in the sense
that if they had been pulled into a
bowling league rather than neo-nazism
those same sort of personal
characteristics and maybe emotional
problems would not have led to
real-world physical violence so that's
where I think I disagree with you well
no I don't think we disagree there
except on the jihadist point I think I
mean the difference is it's just again
this is what I did when I discussed this
on my podcast you know you'd have to
change white supremacy a little bit to
make it a true apples-to-apples
comparison with jihadism and if you made
these changes you would see things
getting worse right you would see it I
mean it's just you'd just imagine if
there were many many more justifications
for white supremacy in the Bible and
they were explicit right and you know
and there was a true doctrine of
martyrdom running throughout the Bible
and it's not just a you know it's not
just the kind of martyrdom that suggests
that people will talk about you after
you're dead but no this is an explicit
promise of paradise if you die under
certain circumstances in this case in
defense of white supremacy right you
know and so there and there were
passages about how important it would be
to you know kill black people or kill
Jews to protect your race right and
these are passages you know uttered by
God himself right so you start adding
that kind of content to the Bible and
adding centuries of support for it and a
much wider community about of people who
believe in martyrdom believe in actual
martyrdom but they're just not really so
into the race war aspect of it right
they're not easily recruited to it but
they actually can't say that much of it
that they can justify theologically
right they just have to kind of fall
silent on the topic right you begin to
make those changes all of a sudden this
begins to look much worse and you will
start attracting people into into that
you know extra
of the the now religion I mean now now
we're talking about this would just be
Christianity you'd attract more normal
people you'd attract people who just are
just sick of being unhappy and and
superficial in their in their lives and
they just want you know spiritual
profundity and somebody gives them the
the holiest book ever written and they
read it and then and then they find that
an honest reading of it aligns almost
perfectly with what Richard Spencer or
someone worse told them was in the book
right that's the problem that the Muslim
world has had to confront and and will
have to confront for as long as we're
alive it's a it's just a major issue you
know this is something that you know
people like Maajid Nawaz and again that
this now connects back to what we've
been talking about how deranged the left
even the mainstream left is on this on
this topic so Maajid Nawaz who's that
you know a brilliant and now impeccably
ethical and liberal reformer of Islam he
started the Quilliam the Quilliam
foundation and you know his his goal is
to just tear Attica lies extremists and
he was a former extremist himself he was
an Islamist who was recruiting for for a
an extremist organization his betrayer
which he was not a terrorist he was not
a jihadist per se he was not getting
ready to blow himself up on an airplane
but he was you know trying to get you
know nuclear weapons into the wrong
hands right he was trying to inspire a
coup in Pakistan and and recruiting
people to to support that project and he
spent four years in a prison in Egypt
for his troubles and but now he's now
he's on the right side of history
totally and and a true friend of mine
and yet because he says honest things
about the problem I've just been
discussing you know the connection
between jihadism and the real religion
of Islam he got put on the
on a list of so-called anti Muslim
extremists by the Southern Poverty Law
Center
now the Southern Poverty Law Center is
most of your listeners will know is the
flagship think tank that finds all the
Nazis in our midst in our midst right
they're the people who sue the KKK and
then the people who tell mainstream
journalists who's who on the extremist
right in in the US and the fact that
they could be so wrong about majah
right I mean they had to pay him over
three million dollars in settlement for
this defamation once he sued them but
the fact that and you know they were
completely unapologetic I mean they
doubled down they tripled down right up
into the point where they had to pay
over three million dollars and and
formally apologize they were the worst
of the worst of the woke on this on this
topic you just need to see you know mark
Potok you know the person who appears to
have authored this opinion on their
behalf I know him interviewed in the
Atlantic over this right I mean he just
he never missed an opportunity to miss
this opportunity to recognize that he
had made a mistake and it's an E and yet
you know this and so this is the kind of
I mean it's become a kind of you know
grift on the left here where these
people are you know they're their
business model is to hunt Nazis and when
they run out of Nazis they start hunting
people like me or maje it or ayaan Hirsi
Ali or Douglas Murray or I mean whoever
you know that they've whoever just
doesn't mouth the most woke opinions on
this and you know it's a problem this
particular problem is across the board
because they're still thought of as the
arbiter of who's who in this space and
they're still referenced endlessly by
mainstream journalists and we know their
algorithm is broken right you know I
wound up on their hate watch page for
for because of as reclines articles
there are many other people who you know
people who I don't agree with people who
are certainly right of of me politically
but
are not white supremacist and not the
gateway to white supremacy who are you
know endlessly maligned by this
organization and yet this is their
utterly mainstream I mean there's no no
one has replaced them as far as I can
tell as a as a source of information
here and so that's a you know yet
another problem yeah I mean I guess you
could say there's overlap with what the
anti-defamation league does but it's not
the same thing yeah and and and this is
you know it's it's just everything is
upside down in this area so you
mentioned the the anti-defamation league
I think it was was it what's the deal
was it the I forget who noticed that you
know Ben Shapiro was the most frequently
attacked that was the ignorant yeah
person in the media by anti-semites and
yet you know he's routinely described as
a white supremacist or you know white
supremacists adjacent for you know for
his political views now Ben and I
disagree about you know certainly most
things politically but it's just the the
fact that you could Eve ever allege that
he has a fondness for Nazis given given
who he is and his life experience and
given you a you know given your own you
know concern for identity politics if
you're someone holding this opinion
about Ben and it's just it's completely
nuts and and yet this is it's a very
mainstream way of you know parsing up
the political landscape at the moment
Sam you've been exceedingly generous
with your time and I really appreciate
that we were able to do this and hope
I'd get the opportunity again yeah yeah
well thank you and it was a long time
coming but great to meet you